on peut se poser s'asseoir discuter sous
l'arbre l'arbre devient un signal dans
le paysage les rendez vous aux jardins à
saint quentin en yvelines se sont
ouverts vendredi dernier par une visite
guidée du parc forestier de la pépinière
à villepreux l'architecte paysagiste
responsable de cet espace était présent
l'idée c'était de vraiment de retrouver
la mémoire du site qui est une ancienne
pépinière de s'approprier cet espace là
et cette culture là pour redessiner un
réseau de parcours de promenade pour
redorer ouvrir le milieu pour pour créer
des milieux de vie
pendant deux heures les participants ont
re découvert un espace qu'ils traversent
quotidiennement
ils étaient une quinzaine à avoir pu
s'inscrire à cette visite également
organisées dans le cadre de la semaine
ville proviennent du développement
durable c'est rare je pense de pouvoir
dialoguer en direct avec le concepteur
même d'un tel espace comment dire
naturel et forestier donc les visiteurs
étaient étaient très curieux et très
demandeur d'informations
cette visite a permis de recueillir le
ressenti des promeneurs du parc
les participants ont donné leur avis on
ne l'a pas fait ou pas de charge
ça c'était agréable et puis j'ai appris
plein de choses
et en plus il y avait une écoute ça
c'est aussi très agréable ce que j'ai pu
poser des questions pour faire des
petites réflexions et ça a été court
bien reçu les rendez vous aux jardins se
sont poursuivies ce week-end dans
l'ensemble de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines